hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments it's on a Tuesday
Tuesday's like we always planned boo boo
boo boo boo bird oh yeah late what of it
like I care about my fans I'm an
no care a piece where I care it's still
gonna be on every Monday I just forgot
about the Sabbath this one's on the
Susan Mitchell program if you were stuck
on an island with PewDiePie dan is not
on fire amazing Phil and jacksepticeye
with one which one would you eats first
sad face happy face well you got a rang
come by you know which one has the most
meat on their bones which one is the
most useful to keep around longer and
which one would put up the most fight if
we tried to eat them so you got ranked
him by that I know PewDiePie's kind of a
scrawny ER guy and jacksepticeye you
know he's not exactly the most athletic
ever Dan and Phil there but they both
got the tall advantage so they got reach
if you try to get him so it's kind of
hard to say I think I'd go for PewDiePie
first you know get whatever stringy meat
I could pull off of his bones and then
they're probably go for Jack next and
then kind of sways Dan and Phil to be on
my side me like I would eat you we're
kings are this island together and I'd
have to take him off by that one because
they're friends and you're gonna betray
me they're all gonna betray me I won't
let them betray me yeah that's who I eat
first anyway what if Mark was not kill
mark can you do speak Spanish for us
your Latin American fans please please
please please please get ready for it
wayde's favorite song
I'm gonna call wait up he loves this so
much Vanja histoy in gato and mis
pantalones and altitude Radio Hudson so
how you doing wait sorry wait say hi
okay I gotta go no I'm the worst friend
ever
are you a goofy goober
well wait would know I'm a goofy goober
but I wouldn't call him twice in a row
he's not no Janet - Janet my tape stop
being so fabulous wouldn't sassy it
hurts my heart no excuse me while I drop
a shitload of tank means drops a
shitload of dag beep sorry did you drop
your means I'm sorry there's I'm
swimming in mayonnaise
can you take them back please jock Hugh
what if boobs were for real or are they
not have every boob I did come across
his boob Allah he is bubut pipe dream
that men have been chasing and women oh
no I could I hope boob is for real if I
had boob I've said this before if I had
boob I would spend all day just playing
with him because boobs are fun
markiplier were you serious about your
posts on Twitter a few weeks ago about
getting a puppy if so give a German
Shepherd they're the cutest and will eat
the faces of your enemies happy you
tubing hey well I'm hoping that I didn't
just cast a horrible spell but I will be
taking home my puppy on Thursday you'll
all see
tons of pictures tons of videos non-stop
you'll get sick of her in a few days I
will spam you with beautiful pictures my
lovely puppy badly mark what if your
tongue was an airplane don't put this in
the video but I killed a guy and threw
him in the ocean while having people
chant your name over and over again oh I
got a megaphone crawl mr. president it's
me again we've got a situation he's
doing some bad buddy looks like
mr. face hello mr. president and for me
okay to the window to the wall doesn't
sweat drop down mom I really want you to
read this comment because if you don't
pewds potato people will come and take
over the world and they will kill you do
you wanna die let me get this straight
the Poots potato people had a meeting
and at this meeting they were all like I
might be a potato but I have standards I
will not kill everyone
unless this tween girl gets a common
word yes my potato Queen Queen King both
we don't have genders oh come here
mister mister mistress I don't have
genders that doesn't mean potatoes don't
like to get freaky with him what kind of
porn do you watch
I actually don't watch porn and no one
is ever gonna believe me on that one
not a soul out there believe me and I
don't what no one's gonna believe me
this sentence is false you ever think
you're gonna write a book I do notice
that there's a lot of youtubers out
there that are writing books these days
and they're mostly about their own lives
but if I was to write a book it would
never be about my life that would
probably the be the most boring subject
you could probably write a book about if
I were to write a book I have a lot of
stories and things that I want to put
into books like actual fictional stories
you know coming up with worlds and
universes like that's something that
really does appeal to me but I never
have the time to write a book because I
have a lot of passions that I want to
pursue but I'm wise enough to know that
I don't have enough time to do
everything so I try to do some things
very well then spread my time out now
down the road a few years of course you
know I'm 26 you know I still have a lot
of time left
hopefully and you know I have a lot of
things that I want to do in my life so
I'm just putting the book thing on the
backburner way back there will you
awfully Photoshop a top hat and monocle
on yourself enid video
no well prank called and wrecked today
was just like every other day poor wait
oh boo hoo boo boo boo boo how do i
adult Marc EMU bless us with your cotton
candy pink wisdom I don't know how to
adult why are you asking me how to adult
I barely know how to function as a human
I if I was thrown into the real world
you know how quickly I would drown when
will drunk minecraft return oh ok so
here is a very Brawley bad news to some
people probably good news to others it's
take it for what it will here's my
little story I cannot process alcohol
properly my body doesn't do it I have a
deficient enzyme that causes a poison to
build up my system because I can't break
down alcohol fully very quickly some
other people have it a lot of people do
have it I cannot process alcohol
correctly but that doesn't mean that I
don't try to drink alcohol ever since I
got into college I've been trying to and
I'm not here to advocate one way or
another be responsible about what you do
and make sure that what you do doesn't
harm anyone else or doesn't harm
yourself to an extreme
that's basically my rule about life so
that's all I'll say about the philosophy
and morals of drinking be responsible
about it but as far as I go
I a few weeks ago when I was back home I
was drinking you know every night not
excessive leave just a few beers and
then I had an incident and it's not a
big deal but the quickest way to
describe it is that I had a bit of a
heart attack now that doesn't mean that
there's anything physically wrong with
my heart don't panic don't shout that
from the rooftop as a horrible thing
literally my heart could not pump enough
blood to get to my head I passed out my
friends were there they got
in ambulance I went to the hospital I
was totally fine there's nothing
physically wrong with my heart
I had a deficient vitamin something
nutritional deficiency as caused by my
body trying to compensate for my broken
enzyme big science bull the doctors
didn't even know exactly what happened
but it was related to me not being able
to process alcohol correctly combined
with stress and other things cause what
happened but what this means is that I
who already didn't drink very much
because I couldn't drink very much
because I can't enjoy it all the time
can no longer drink Drakh doctor's
orders I cannot drink again it is bad
for my health it will not do me any good
to drink and frankly I am a hundred
percent okay with it
I am totally okay with never having
another drink in my life that doesn't
mean that I'm gonna go out and be like
no one should drink if I can't have her
no one can I don't honestly care if you
do or do not drink so long as my rules
it doesn't harm anyone else or yourself
so everything in moderation that's all
I'll say about it but frankly I can't
drink and what that means is that drunk
Minds minecraft as what it is can't
continue it just can't it's logical it
came medically I cannot drink and I will
not force myself to drink to do a series
just have a little bit more fun when me
and my friends still have fun in amazing
ways and I love it to death playing with
these guys without alcohol like it's
totally fine it's not a big deal for me
it just means that drunk minecraft as
people know it will probably never
continue because I literally cannot
drink it's like literally literally I
cannot drink so that's the long it was a
long story but you know I I just need to
get the elephant out of the room because
I've been wondering how I was gonna talk
about this and obviously I talked about
it there it is and I want to be very
clear very clear I can't make enough
hand gestures to be very clear about
this I'm fine nothing physically wrong
with my heart heart is healthy they
checked me out I am healthy I am good
I'm not going to the hospital
anymore I didn't tell anybody about this
because they didn't want people to panic
again that I was in the hospital and I
don't plan to go back to the hospital
anytime soon I've been there too much in
my life as it is but I am fine I just
can't drink anymore that's the end of
that story so there we go
mark you have a beautiful singing voice
can you please sing something in the
next reading your comments video it
would be awesome
you got it Ariana this is just for you
it's been a long December and I'm
beginning to believe that it might not
be as good as the last so that's all the
comments for this video thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
everybody who provided a comment and if
you want your comment to be in the next
video
write your comment down in the
description below I pick from a huge
variety of times times a day I look for
new comments old comments all the
comments and I enjoy reading you guys
his weird weird comments but both
serious and weird this time so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye